whoa it's action chess with a raid
thanks action chess shout out to action
chess
appreciate that okay that was very good
timing because i'm about to start
a new game a blindfold game
um and chat can very much be involved
so how this will work people people chat
can probably explain
but basically i'm playing a bot which is
the twitch chat
and the twitch chat will vote for a move
that uh yeah anyone in the chat can just
type a move
and then the highest voted for move will
be played
um so yeah we can see the stats here
and we can see the chat going wild here
but it's time for me to put on my
blindfold
i've already won all the games i think
i've played three games so far
so this is the next challenge good luck
to i guess good luck to the chat
behave yourself and
i move this up a little bit
d4 okay d4
whoa last time was e4 mixing up the
openings
uh i'll play knight f6 knight f6 i have
a feeling i know it's coming
it might be close though if i had to
guess i would guess bishop f4 is coming
but there might be a lot of
traditionalists
who play c4
just have to wait and see
knight c3 is also a move
c4 oh c4 okay do i play the budapest
or do i play something solid
let's play e5
yeah let's play the budapest
it is nice uh p people can't troll kiwi
2
at least when they play d4 on move one
so i'm imagining overwhelming majority
we'll play d takes e5 there's probably a
few a few votes for
d5 like d5 and d takes e5 are probably
the only two
maybe one vote for e2 yeah let's play
knight g4 knight g4
okay so budapest accepted
had this position many times before i'm
sure people in the chat are
at least familiar with this position
so there are a few main moves here
there's actually a lot of candidate
moves
i don't want to say anything too too
revealing
oh i can defend the pawn we can give
away the pawn knight f3
i can play knight f3 bishop c5
i think most stronger players play
bishop f4
instead of knight f3 because the
drawback of knight f3
is exactly this
now white has to play e3 and then the
bishop on c1 is blocked in
and then i'll very easily win back the
pawn
knights knight c6 is coming
e3 knight c6
yeah so just attacking the pawn one more
time
both knights have the same targets
there is a line um i
probably wouldn't expect this from chat
but there is a move here queen d5
to hit the pawn and the bishop
but then queen g5 can be met with
queenie's c3
queen e7 would attack and defend knight
c3 let's um
play knight g e5 knight g takes e5
i'm just developing normally white
four minutes 53 seconds black
seven minutes two seconds
oh i have more time
oh i guess i'm gaining time yeah there's
there's some kind of 30 second
increments
that's nice
so now it takes e5 oh yeah okay knight
takes
the plan is just a castle complete
development
and then later at least eventually
checkmate
a trade of trade of nights are actually
kind of nice this white has a little bit
more space with the pawn on c4
the position's a little bit easier to
play
extracting two yeah
jinx i'll play
rookies wait like castle already maybe i
didn't castle
king side castle there we go i gotta
head myself
yeah i'm already thinking like forward
into the middle game
okay white's probably gonna castle
chat was having troubles castling the
previous game
because you have to type 0-0
i think you can also type the starting
square in the destination square
i don't know if it works for castling
kingside castle
if i wanted to type like a7 a5
a5 uh that's one approach
oh i forgot to play rookie 8
yeah black should play rookie at first
but a5 is an idea
yeah it wasn't necessary to type a7 a5
there
but it's another way like if if two
pieces can move to the same square
that's called like uci notation play
rookie
yeah so the rook usually
almost all the time goes to e8
it's only half one file i support my
knights
eric flip the board so we see white
oh oh
can i do that i would have to take off
my blindfold
oh bishop e2 that's a fair point
there should be coordinates though i'm
pretty sure i have coordinates enabled
bishop e2 bishop e2
bishop e2
didn't the bishop bishop b2 oh bishop
bishop b2
b2 okay so let's say the bishop's
already on e2
have a hard time hearing the b's let's
play rook a6
rook a6
so i'm i'm going for this very very
typical
like budapest middle game plan i've had
this so many times
on stream
so chat knows what's coming hopefully
or maybe not i don't know
i have a few youtube videos covering
this idea
actually i made like a budapest series
it was like a three video series on my
youtube channel
it was back i played knight g6 knight g6
back in 20 2019
it was like january 2019.
there's also one like st louis chess
club lecture video
i cover this line f4 is a good move
though
f4 might be the the engine
recommendation
maybe i should be scared dwight four
minutes 28 seconds
black queen takes e7 what
queen takes d7 queen takes d7 that's
hilarious
so the the trolls prevailed with the
trolls prevail
queen takes d7 wow
and yeah as someone said earlier this is
why we can't have nice things
white was playing so well too like doing
everything developing
not plundering anything not developing
the king
and then just gives away a queen
i wonder if boat has raided and then
everyone just wanted to botes gambit
a small possibility king f2 oh here we
go
the self-destruction has begun wait king
f2 is that a free pawn
knight takes f4 i think that's a free
pawn because
the pawn on e3 is pinned
i'm expecting king what am i expecting
something like king f3
did the bishop go the bishop went to b2
i believe
oh so the epon is also hanging
white resigned whoa black is victorious
you can resign
i didn't know that was possible
how did you guys do that i didn't know
you could vote for resigning
oh that was very tragic
bishop e2 it seems like all the games
you play well and then you just make one
terrible terrible mistake
oh just by typing resign oh
can you do the same thing with offering
draws
rookie eight bishop e2 yeah
overzone resign is the new king e2
yeah i guess uh king f2 the bishop was
preventing
the move in that position queen takes d7
uh which position give me a
move number also let me turn off speech
for now
maybe did you mouse slip maybe chat
mouse slipped
meant to play queen d5 whoa it's bobo
baggage
the wind bits i don't know if i should
be so proud of that win
but maybe i am thanks for the win bits
it took a lot of hard work deciding
which piece to take back with
analysis board oh
oh i could have taken on e3
that would have been so sly i was so
focused on the queen
some twisted misdirection
oh there's bishop oh i guess for some
reason
i was still seeing this phantom bishop
on c1 move 11 i think
yeah i should have i should have
identified this oh
actually this could have been really
nice
i should have done this and then
if i saw this i would have seen this
oops
rook h6 i'm curious how many people in
chat would take the knight
because then rook takes h2 and then
would mate so so nice
uh andrew chess is a programmer of this
uh yeah i think thanks again andrew
chess for anyone just joining
andrew chess is a the reason why we we
have
nice things sometimes
but but then the people the people who
who play queen diggs e7 sometimes ruin
those nice things
so yeah it would be funny to like
blacklist
certain moves
i mean there's so many ideas to
i could just ban anyone who's suggesting
you too
that would kind of be mean though
anyway if you want if you want a cool
opening to play and smooth the past
um i've shown this trap before
oh subscriber only chat could be
interesting too
because then there there might be less
trolls i don't know how many of my
subscribers are trolls but
that could be interesting oh ezra zev
just
okay just enabled sub only chat
are we free of the trolls i was gonna
show one trap in case there's anyone who
actually plays the budapest
or plays against the budapest if you're
white
uh what you can do is play
bishop d2 in this position sub
only white so we see right side up
i'll do that next game there are
coordinates though so you should be able
to figure out
i'll do that because i'll be nice to you
what's the line here oh maybe there's a
sign yeah
play bishop d2 and after it takes takes
takes
bishop c3 and it's a cool idea because
very natural move looks like looks like
d6 for black
but then white wins a piece here
let's test chat white to move and win a
piece
oh assuming people didn't see
the opening book also gideon esquire
thanks for subbing with prime yeah good
job
good job finney finney and azerive so b4
and then c5 is just it's winning a piece
bishop the bishop on c3 makes it
possible
or makes this tactic possible i should
say